No matter what kind of stories you like, 2018
was a pretty great year for movies.
The best ones served up scenes that took over
pop culture, becoming instantly iconic.
These are the moments from our favorite movies
of the year that we'll still be talking about
for years to come.
The Mission: Impossible series has become
a reliable adrenaline delivery system, and
2018's Fallout was no exception.
The movie's setpieces are all impressive,
but the helicopter chase is the most breathtaking,
with Cruise actually learning to fly so he
could perform the scene's aerial maneuvers.
Talk about raising the bar.
"Not when I'm this close!
Come on!
Come on!"
A Star is Born is a classic showbiz fable,
and one of 2018's biggest hits.
The scene in which Lady Gaga's Ally takes
the stage with Bradley Cooper's Jackson Maine
for the first time was instantly iconic.
"Come sing that that song that I love.”
“No I can’t do that.”
“Wait.. that’s not funny."
The song, "Shallow," was a chart-topping sensation,
standing alone outside the context of the
film.
But it makes for an incredible dramatic moment
in the movie's story too, one that's guaranteed
to linger in viewers' memories for years to
come.
"Can I tell you a secret?
You might be a songwriter."
Bohemian Rhapsody could have ended with Freddie
Mercury's death, but instead, the story wrapped
up on a high point: Queen's legendary set
at 1985's Live Aid.
Many consider the performance to be among
the best rock sets ever, which the bio-pic
faithfully recreated.
"Thank you for making this a great occasion."
While only three songs made the movie's final
cut, the 20 minute, six song set was filmed
in its entirety, which fans will get to see
as an extra feature for the movie's home release.
A Quiet Place was one of 2018's more unexpected
hits, a nail-biting sci-fi thriller from director
John Krasinski, Nothing was a better testament
to his craftsmanship as a filmmaker than the
harrowing childbirth sequence, in which Emily
Blunt's character goes into labor while alien
beasts scour the house around her.
Going into labor is a noisy experience, so
watching Blunt's character try and get through
it without making a sound was unbearably tense.
It's the best sequence in the movie, and one
of the most memorable scenes of the year.
Marvel's Black Panther was one of 2018's biggest
hits, filled with memorable locations and
magnetic performances.
Everyone has their own favorite character,
but Danai Gurira's Okoye gets what's arguably
the movie's most crowd-pleasing sequence.
In the movie's casino scene, Gurira steals
the show with an iconic moment that's both
hilarious and badass.
The scene starts with the heroes undercover,
with Okoye donning a wig to better blend in.
She's not a fan of it.
"Bast willing, this will go quickly and I
can get this ridiculous thing off my head."
"Looks nice — just whip it back and forth."
"What?"
When the group's cover is blown, the warrior
wastes no time in whipping off her wig, and
weaponizing it.
It's not often that an action scene can make
such a clear statement about beauty standards,
but Black Panther pulled it off with style
— literally.
Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse won over
audiences everywhere, bringing Marvel character
Miles Morales to the big screen for the first
time.
Miles is a different kind of Spider-Man, full
of youthful exuberance and insecurity, which
his debut played up in winning fashion.
“When do I know, that I’m Spider-Man?”
When Miles gets his powers, he isn't sure
if he's ready to take up the mantle of Spider-Man.
After he receives guidance from other dimensions'
more experienced Spider-People, he learns
the lesson that he'll never be ready — he
just has to take a leap of faith.
"What's Up Danger"
2018's most iconic scene came at the climax
of Avengers: Infinity War, and you already
know the one we're talking about.
"You should've gone for the head."
The moment in which the Mad Titan Thanos accomplishes
his goal of snuffing out half of all life
was one of the most mindblowing sequences
the superhero genre has ever seen, instantly
becoming known simply as "The Snap."
Audiences watched in horror as Black Panther,
Doctor Strange, and more crumbled to dust,
ending the movie on a devastating cliffhanger.
"I don't feel so good.”
“I don’t know what’s happening?”
“I don't wanna go."
It's a sequence that spawned a thousand memes,
endless speculation, and left fans wondering
how on Earth they could wait a year to see
the story conclude.
The moment was a gamble, but it paid off big
time with an unforgettable scene that's unlike
anything that's come before it, comic book
movie or not.
Audiences could have revolted — instead,
we're all waiting at the edge of our seats
to see how the story will end.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.